Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today is going to be a really fun day
where we do this, and this, and this.
In a previous episode, we talked about creating
virtual characters with a skeletal system,
adding more than 300 muscles and teaching
them to use these muscles to kick, jump,
move around and perform other realistic human
movements. You see the activated muscles with red.
I am loving the idea, which, turns out,
comes with lots of really interesting
corollaries. For instance, this simulation
realistically portrays how increasing the
amount of weight to be lifted changes
what muscles are being trained during
a workout. These agents also learned to
jump really high and you can see a drastic
difference between the movement required
for a mediocre jump and an amazing one.
And now, scientists at NVIDIA had a crazy idea.
They said, what if we take a similar model, and
ask it to learn to walk from scratch.
Now that is indeed a crazy idea,
because they proposed a model that is
driven by over 150 muscle-tendon units,
and is thus very difficult to
control. So, let’s see how it went.
First, it started to…umm…hello? Well, A+ for
effort, but unfortunately, this is not a great
start. But don’t despair! A little later, it
learned to…well, fall in a different direction,
however, at least some learning is hopefully
happening. Look. I wouldn’t say that it has
finally taken the first step, but at least it
is attempting to take a first step. Is that good
news? Let’s see! Oh yes, yes it is! Because a
little later, it learned to jog. This concept
really works! And, if we wait for a bit longer,
we see that it learned to run as well. Fantastic!
Now, let’s have a closer look and see if the
colors of the muscles indeed show us which
ones are activated at a given moment. And that’s
right! When slowing the footage down, we see the
difficulty of the problem - and that is, different
tendons need to be moved every single moment.
So, while we look at this technique learning
other tasks, we ask one of the most important
questions here, and that is, how fast did it learn
to run? It had to control a 150 different tendons
continuously over time, without falling. So how
long did it take? Did it take days? And now,
hold on to your papers, because it hasn’t taken
days. It only takes minutes. After starting out
like this, by the 17-minute mark, it has learned
so much that it could jog. How amazing is that?
And that is one of the key value propositions of
this paper. It can not only teach this AI agent
difficult tasks, but it can also learn up to
15 to 17-times faster than previous techniques.
That is absolutely amazing. Bravo! So, it seems
that we now have learning-based algorithms that
could teach even a complex, muscle-actuated
robot to walk. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!